he said without concepts there can be no
thought and without analogies that can
be no concepts you know in a Santa Fe
presentation you said that it should be
one of the mantras of AI yes and that
you all see yourself said how to form
and fluidly use concept is the most
important open problem in AI yes how to
form and fluidly use concepts is the
most important open problem in AI so
let's what is the concept and what is an
analogy a concept is in some sense a
fundamental unit of thought so say we
have a concept of a dog okay
and a concept is embedded in a whole
space of concepts so that there's
certain concepts that are closer to it
or farther away from it are these
concept are they really like fundamental
like we mentioned in NATO almost like X
geomatic like very basic and then
there's other stuff built on top of it
or just include everything is are there
complicated like you can certainly have
form new concepts right I guess that's
the question mass yeah
can you form new concepts that our
company complex combinations of other
yes absolutely and that's kind of what
we we do you know learning and then
what's the role of analogies in that so
analogy is when you recognize that one
situation is essentially the same as
another situation and essentially is
kind of the key word there and because
it's not the same so if I say last week
I did a podcast interview in actually
like three days ago in Washington DC and
that situation was very similar to this
situation although it wasn't exactly the
same you know it was a different person
sitting across from me we had different
kinds of microphones the questions were
different
the building was different there's all
kinds of different things but really it
was analogous or I can say so by doing a
podcast interview that's kind of a
constant it's a new concept you know I
never had that concept before I mean and
I can make an analogy with it like being
interviewed for a news article in a
newspaper and I can say well you kind of
play the same role that the the
newspaper the reporter played it's not
exactly the same because maybe they
actually emailed me some written
questions rather than talking and the
writing the written questions play that
you know are analogous to your spoken
questions you know there's just all
kinds of this somehow probably connects
to conversations you have over
Thanksgiving dinner just general
conversations you can there's like a
thread you can probably take that just
stretches out in all aspects of life
that connect to this podcast
I mean sure conversations between humans
sure and and if I go and tell a friend
of mine about this podcast interview my
friend might say oh the same thing
happened to me you know let's say you
know you ask me some really hard
question and I have trouble answering it
my friend could say the same thing
happened to me but it was like it wasn't
a podcast interview it wasn't it was a
completely different situation and yet
my friend is seen essentially this the
same thing you know we say that very
fluidly the same thing happened to me
essentially the same thing we don't even
say that right things they imply it yes
yeah and the view that kind of what went
into say copycat that that whole thing
is that that that that act of saying the
same thing happened to me is making an
analogy and in some sense that's what's
underlies all of our concepts why do you
think analogy making that you're
describing is so fundamental to
cognition
it seems like it's the main element
action of what we think of us cognition
yeah so it can be argued that all of
this generalization we do concepts and
recognizing concepts in different
situations is done by analogy that
that's every time I'm recognizing that
say you're a person that's by analogy
because I have this concept of what
person is and I'm applying it to you and
every time I recognize a new situation
like one of the things I talked about it
in the book was the the concept of
walking a dog mm-hmm that that's
actually making an analogy because all
that you know the details are very
different so it's so now--so reasoning
could be reduced on to sense your
analogy making so all the things we
think of as like yeah like you said
perception so what's perception is
taking raw sensory input and it's
somehow integrating into our our
understanding of the world updating the
understanding and all of that has just
this giant mess of analogies that are
being made I think so yeah if you just
linger on it a little bit like what what
do you think it takes to engineer a
process like that for us in our
artificial systems we need to understand
better I think how how we do it how
humans do it and it comes down to
internal models I think you know people
talk a lot about mental models that
concepts are mental models that I can in
my head I can do a simulation of a
situation like walking a dog and that
there there's some work in psychology
that promotes this idea that all of
concepts are really mental see
nations that whenever you encounter a
concept or situation in the world or you
read about it or whatever you do some
kind of mental simulation that allows
you to predict what's going to happen to
develop expectations of what's going to
happen mm-hmm
so that's the kind of structure I think
we need is that kind of mental model
that and the in our brain somehow these
mental models are very much inter
connected again so a lot of stuff we're
talking about it they're essentially
open problems right so if I ask a
question I don't mean that you would
know the answer already just
hypothesizing but how big do you think
is the the network graph data structure
of concepts that's in our head like if
we're trying to build that ourselves
like it's we take it and that's one of
the things we take for granted we think
I mean that's why we take common-sense
for granted within common sense is
trivial but how big of a thing of
concepts is on that underlies what we
think of as common sense for example
yeah I don't know and I'm not I don't
even know what units to measure it in
beautifully put right but but you know
we have you know it's really hard to
know we have what a hundred billion
neurons or something I don't know and
they're connected via trillions of
synapses and there's all this chemical
processing going on there's just a lot
of capacity for the stuff and they're
informations encoded in different ways
in the brain it's encoded in chemical
interactions it's encoded and electric
like firing and firing rates and and
nobody really knows how it's encoded but
it just seems like there's a huge amount
of capacity so I think it's it's huge
it's just enormous and it's amazing how
much stuff we know yeah and but we know
and not just know like facts but it's
all integrated into
thing that we can make analogies with
yes there's a dream of Semantic Web and
there's there's a lot of Dreams from
expert systems of building giant
knowledge bases do you see a hope for
these kinds of approaches of building of
converting Wikipedia into something that
could be used in analogy making sure and
I think people have have made some
progress along those lines I mean people
have been working on this for a long
time but the problem is and this I think
was is is the problem of common sense
like people have been trying to get
these common sense networks here at MIT
there's this concept net project right
but the problem is that as I said most
of the knowledge that we have isn't
invisible to us it's not in Wikipedia
it's very basic things about you know
intuitive physics intuitive psychology
to ative metaphysics all that stuff if
you were to create a website that
described intuitive physics intuitive
psychology would it be bigger or smaller
than Wikipedia what do you think
I guess describe to whom no that's very
really good yeah right yeah that's a
hard question because you know how do
you represent that knowledge is the
question right I can certainly write
down F equals MA and Newton's laws and a
lot of physics can be deduced from that
uh but that's probably not the best
representation of that knowledge for for
doing the kinds of reasoning we want a
machine to do so so I don't know it's
it's it's impossible to say yeah and you
know the projects like there's a famous
the famous psych project right that
Douglas Lynott did that was trying still
going I think it's still going and if
the the idea was to try and encode all
of common-sense knowledge including all
this invisible knowledge
in some kind of logical representation
and it just never I think could do any
of the things that he was hoping it
could do because that's just the wrong
approach of course that's what they
always say you know and then the history
books will say well the psych project
finally found a breakthrough in 2058 or
something and it did you know we're so
much progress has been made in just a
few decades that yeah okay knows what
the next breakthroughs will be it could
be it's certainly a compelling notion
what the psych project stands for
I think Len it was one of the earliest
people to say common sense is what we
need and that's what we need all this
like expert system stuff that is not
going to get you to AI you need common
sense and he basically gave up his whole
academic career to to go pursue that and
I am Iron III think that the approach
itself will not what do you think he's
wrong with approach what kind of
approach would might be successful
well again you think he knows the answer
right I knew that you know one of my
talks one of the people in the audience
is a public lecture one of the people in
the audience said what AI companies are
you investing in extra funds to invest
but also like no one knows what's gonna
work in AI right that's the problem let
me ask another impossible question in
case you have a sense in terms of data
structures that will store this kind of
information do you think they've been
invented yet both in hardware and
software or is something else needs to
be are we totally you know I think
something else has to be invented I
that's my guess is the breakthroughs
this most promising would that be in
hardware and software do you think we
can get far with the current computer
or do we need to do something you saying
I don't know if Turing computation is
gonna be sufficient probably I would
guess it will I don't I don't see any
reason why we need anything else
but so so in that sense we have invented
the hardware we need but we just need to
make it faster and bigger and we need to
figure out the right algorithms and and
the right sort of architecture touring
that's a very mathematical notion when
we try to have to build intelligence
it's not an engineering notion where you
throw all that stuff well I guess I
guess it is a it is a question that
there people have brought up this
question you know and when you asked
about like is our current hardware will
our current Hardware work well Turing
computation says that like our current
hardware is in principle a Turing
machine right so all we have to do is
make it faster and bigger but there have
been people like Roger Penrose if you
might remember that he said Turing
machines cannot produce intelligence
because intelligence requires continuous
valued numbers I mean that was sort of
my reading of his argument and quantum
mechanics and what else whatever you
know but I don't see any evidence for
that that we need new computation
paradigms but I don't know if we're you
know I don't think we're going to be
able to scale up our current approaches
to programming these computers
you